[Applause]
hi jonah hi
drew it's wonderful to see you again how
are you oh
jonah oh i can't have a week go by where
we're not hanging out i mean you are
just
since 2019 and you and i decided to go
on this journey together i am just so
thrilled to be here okay jonah let's get
right into the news
you have some t-rex information
oh yes today i'm reporting on a story
that there's
now a dinosaur named stan and he is the
most
complete t-rex fossil out there is
and it's actually in rockefeller center
and it's about the auction
on october 6th for six to eight million
dollars
and i really want it i did the math
i did the math and it would take 35 000
afghans
by october 6th but i really want it so
could you take a picture
for could you take a picture of it for
me and send it to me
it's right there in rockefeller center
yeah i'll make a phone call and see if
we can get in
and at the very least do that maybe i'll
just try and you know
i don't know i'll see what kind of deal
i can work but that is a hefty price tag
my god all right in other news
um and i want to get you everything you
want jonah gosh darn it all right i'm
gonna i'm gonna see what i can do
uh picture wise at least all right some
talented woodworkers are building and
giving dust to kids
what do you know about this oh yeah this
has been trending all over the country
there's woodworkers that are now making
desks for kids and donating them to them
and that is so important because
as a virtual learner myself and as so
many others are right now
you need a you need a workspace your own
space to do your school
and i'm finishing this story off by
letting you know
that i love it when i see another fellow
human using their handicraft and their
talent
to do good for others like i do with my
crochet
i love you jonah i really do and i agree
um and we talk so much about education
jonah and so
the fact that these craftsmen are doing
this in the
you know for the sake of education i
just i know that you and i are
you know that's a big priority for us um
okay
you're a crocheting product prodigy
obviously
what's going on in the crochet news
world
well there's two stories i'm reporting
on but the first one
is about the goldman girls there's now a
golden girls book
where you can crochet the golden girls
and
the one i have my eye on making is
sophia
because she is my favorite because she
knits
i mean i'm primarily a crocheter but i
do respect those knitters
yeah absolutely and you know what fun
fact i think
she was the youngest person and played
the oldest right estelle
getty yeah she was actually the youngest
cast member in age
but played the older oldest lady of the
group
um okay and in other creation crochet
news is there one more
crochet oh by the way this really gets
the my the lisp and me
crochet kitty couches
oh yes this is the big breaking news
story that i can't
wait bring it on so right now
everybody's making kitty couches and it
was originally a pattern that was made
30 years ago by my pattern book
publisher annie's
and they're sold okay but in the past
couple months it went
crazy it would they went viral on the
internet and now everybody's making them
and i had requests to make one for
people for my instagram
thousands of requests really and i had
the time
but now i made one and i'm here to
reveal it to you
and this is the first this has never
been seen before this is
jonah's like premier kitty couch
oh my gosh jonah can i get in line with
the thousands of people because we have
our two cats lucky and peach
and oh i was just gonna ask if you had a
cat but
if you certainly like it you could have
it
are you serious jonah yep it'll be a
trade out i get my dinosaur picture and
you get the cat couch
oh my god jonah i'm so excited okay
until next week
um and we're doing um some really
amazing reviews
on movies that we both love and i can't
wait
and uh until next week jonah i will be
waiting
lucky and peach that is a throne that is
the most
fabulous in cat accoutrement oh my gosh
thank you jonah i love you